foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you again
[Music]
foreign
good morning everybody please take your
seats
I'm extremely pleased to see everybody
here for this debate we're going to
continue
with the session that is now resumed the
first item on our agenda this morning
are Council commission statements on the
preparation of the EU Ukraine Summit
the first speaker on part of the council
is
Paul Johnson Minister for defense you
have the floor sir
president honorable members commissioner
I would like to thank the European
Parliament for its strong and continued
engagement on Ukraine your interest in
the preparations of tomorrow's 24th EU
Ukraine Summit is much welcome
it this will be the first summit since
Russia launched its full-scale Invasion
and also the first one since Ukraine was
granted EU candidate status
then you will use this occasion to
reiterate our message loud and clear
the EU is strongly condemning Russia's
unprovoked and unjustified war of
aggression against Ukraine and it will
continue supporting Ukraine as long as
it takes
both politically financially military
and with humilitarian Aid
in response to Russia's aggression and
with the support of this Parliament the
EU has so far mobilized over 37 billion
euros including 18 billion euros on
microfinancial support packages for
2023. the estimate total amount of EU
and member States Military Support is
about 12 billion euros this brings the
overall support of the EU and its member
states to Ukraine close to 50 billion
euros
in addition the EU has offered
assistance to the millions of ukrainians
who have fled the war our combined
pressure on Russia and other responsible
actors through nine packages of sanction
is also unprecedented cutting off Russia
from the technology and revenues it
needs to continue its war of aggression
we will continue working on restrictive
measures and their full implementation
honorable members EU Ukraine bilateral
relations are stronger than ever the EU
has obtained the status of EU candidate
country tomorrow the EU leaders will
reiterate our support and encouragement
to Ukraine's reform efforts which are
particularly impressive considering
these difficult times and we will commit
to further deepening our relationship
including through the new priority
action plan for the DC FTA
2023-2024 is in Ukraine's access to our
internal markets
at tomorrow's Summit you will reconfirm
its support to Ukraine's Swift relieved
and Reconstruction from the the mining
from everything from D mining to Health
and Rehabilitation
you will reiterate our support for
president zelenski's Initiative for just
peace and underlying that the eu's
commitment to working with the Ukraine
to mobilize broad international support
it will it is important to underline
that Ukraine's genuine stance for peace
Russia has not displaced such a
willingness on the country Russia
continues intensifying its brutal war of
aggression with global consequences
including when it comes to food security
honorable members allow me to praise
once again the active and Swift support
of this Parliament for the eu's macro
financial assistance to Ukraine Ukraine
now has a predictable financing schedule
for this year
Ukraine receives the first branches of 3
billion euros when no other
international funds for 2023 had yet
reached the country we also welcome this
Parliament strong political stance
expressed in various resolutions in
support of Ukraine and condemning
Russia's planted violation of the
international order
let me be clear those responsible for
war crimes and the other most serious
crimes will be held accountable we will
continue supporting the investigations
by the international criminal court
there can be no impunity of the crimes
committed on the Russian occupation
we will also need to work to ensure the
accountability of for the crime of
aggression tomorrow's Summit will once
again demonstrate that the EU will
continue supporting Ukraine for as long
as it takes thank you very much for your
attention
foreign
thank you very much Minister we'll now
continue with the commission and on
behalf of the commission commissioner
Han has the floor
members
today and tomorrow the first ever
College to government meeting with
Ukraine and the 24th EU Ukrainian Summit
will take place in Kiev they will send a
very clear message to Ukraine and Bianca
about our continued unwavering support
to Ukraine for as long as it takes and
our Collective strengths and to resolve
encountering Russia's brutal aggression
the college to government meeting at the
summit will provide an opportunity to
take stock of the Union's ongoing
support to Ukraine across all areas
including Financial
humanitarian energy budget support
military support and diplomatic Outreach
we will discuss the reform efforts by
Ukraine the further alignment of its
legislation we see you a key and we will
outline further steps to enhance
sectoral cooperation Ukraine's Destiny
is in Europe our common European past
was just I did last June by granting the
status of candidate country to Ukraine
the commission will support Ukraine
throughout the whole accession process
despite the continuing ruthless attacks
of the aggressor we are seeing a major
momentum of reforms in Ukraine of course
as we will know the new accession pass
is a marathon not a Sprint the European
Council will decide on the next steps
unanimously the discussions in Kiev
today and tomorrow will focus on reform
priorities and the steps necessary to
help Ukraine further line its
legislation to the union a key following
the commission's analytical report which
was just published complementing the
commission's opinion on Ukraine's EU
membership application to support the
reform process and increase Ukraine's
resilience we're announcing a new
support package worth 400 million euro
in including 145 million euro in
humanitarian assistance and 305 million
euro in bilateral cooperation the
commission also confirmed to the
Ukrainian government that the setting up
of the Secretariat of the multi-age
agency tunnels coordination platform in
Brussels is progressing well including
preparation for the convents from G7
countries and other partners this
announcement followed the first meeting
on the 26th of January of the steering
committee of the donors coordination
platform the coordination platform will
be key to help match needs and resources
for Ukraine's repair recovery and
reconstruction efforts Ukraine's
accession process works together with
its integration of internal Market the
basis of our relationship was already
strong with the association agreement
and its deep and comprehensive free
trade area
the suspension of all tariffs and trade
defense measures on Ukraine Imports
through the autonomous trade measures
has benefited both sides despite the
very difficult circumstances we will
propose to extend these measures soon we
will also discuss with Ukraine our
support across all relevant areas such
as Ukraine's Association to additional
EU programs which will strengthen its
economy moreover president thunderline
will propose a suspension of Ukraine's
Financial contributions for
participation in Union programs for as
long as Ukraine's Financial challenges
remain as we urgently continue to cut
off Russians and fossil fuel Imports a
memorandum of understanding on
Renewables gases will be also endorsed
the Strategic partnership in this area
reflects the significant potential in
Ukraine and the high degree of
integration of Renewables in the energy
market and in structure Ukraine's
reconstruction canopy dissociated from
Russia's responsibility for its war of
aggression the atrocities committed by
Russia in Ukraine will not go unpunished
and all options are on the table to
ensure full investigation and
prosecution we support the development
of an international center for the
prosecution of crime of aggression in
Ukraine in The Hague the objective would
be to coordinate investigations of the
crime of aggressions against Ukraine and
preserve and store evidence for future
trials this coordination Center would be
linked to the existing joint
investigation team supported by our just
the colleagues Russia's military
aggression has shown that Ukraine
belongs to Europe we share the same
values the same aspiration for democracy
and freedom and we will stay United for
as long as it takes
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much commissioner Han
that brings us to the initial round of
speakers on behalf of the groups first
of all for the group of European
People's Party Mr Gala again thank you
very much president ladies and gentlemen
what can you say in one minute first of
all Ukraine has to win this war
otherwise it's going to go on
uh add infant item and of course that
will affect the status of the Free World
secondly we have to continue our
comprehensive support as long as it's
needed I think there's broad ranging
consensus for this political military
Financial humanitarian support
I also agree with what the commissioner
said the Russian crimes will have to be
registered in a systematic basis to make
sure that the appropriate legal
consequences can be drawn
we have to make sure that the crime of
aggression must be prosecuted
reconstruction has to go hand in hand
with the requirements of the accession
process that means we can't see a return
to Old structures we have to with
reconstruction C reform
also on domestic politics side we have
to make sure that during the war there
aren't false structures established or
laws adopted which at the end of the day
are not actually compatible with EU law
during the war we have to keep a
watching brief on making sure that false
Trends aren't followed thank you very
much Mr Gala now on behalf of the
progressive Alliance of socialists and
Democrats their chair Miss cassia Perez
gracias
didn't
24th of February will be marking one
year since the beginning of Putin's
invasion of Ukraine a war that caused a
level of Destruction ruined that are
difficult to imagine in the Europe the
21st century we have witnessed the
suffering of the Ukrainian people the EU
is coherent and a standing firm
in
um when it comes to the difficulties in
Ukraine we have helped in so many ways
politically we have forgiven
humanitarian Aid military economic and
financial aid and we have helped fight
against impunity
total Aid to the tune of 49 billion Euro
that means that the EU and its member
states are the main supporters of
Ukraine and the summit that is going to
take place tomorrow in Kiev not only has
to bolster Unity between Ukraine and the
EU but also has to bolster the unity
among member states it's only if we
stand United that we can move forward
and create trust our response to Putin
has Illustrated the potential of the EU
when difficult decisions have to be
taken when it comes to the Kiev Summit
Putin has to recognize our real
power and strength for every Refugee
that has to flee their home we will
respond with the extraordinary humanity
and solidarity shown by our societies
for every home hospital and school that
is destroyed we're going to come down
hard with sanctions in order to invest
in the Reconstruction of Ukraine and
make sure that we tap into the 300
billion Euro of Frozen Russian reserves
and for each home that Putin has left
without heating Hot Water and
Light then we will build hydrogen
pipelines to help and for every man
woman and child that has been despicably
assassinated by Putin we will respond
with International Justice and every
time there's a cry for help from
President zielinski we will respond with
the power of military capabilities
sending Heaven Weaponry is a difficult
decision but we've got to do so if we
want to avoid a deadlock and to that
will freeze the war until Ukraine is
reduced to ashes Putin cannot win the
war and just wants Ukraine to be
exhausted and for allies on both sides
of the Atlantic to get tired Military
Support is vital in order to Halt the
half a million troops that Russia will
deploy in the spring and go back in
order to go go back to the positions
before the 24th of February last year
and to make sure that the Ukrainian
government can engage in peace talks
under favorable conditions
Ukraine's Victory will not only keep the
European dream of its people alive but
should also be the reward that our
society's
deserve for the huge sacrifices made
from the beginning of the war
turning on the heating turning on lights
doing the shopping or tanking up your
car have meant personal sacrifices and
the public authorities have to provide
support for this the EU Ukraine Summit
has to be used in order to send out a
clear message to the Ukraine on its
European path Ukraine needs rule of law
with robust institutions that will
protect its citizens and that will
protect their rights they will come to
the end of this path and the Ukraine
will be able to offer the EU what the EU
gets from all this member states
democracy economic growth and social
cohesion the EU is one of the strongest
Global Powers we are bold and open to
the world we are responsible power that
strives for peace and if we trust our
Union there are reasons to look towards
the future filled with hope and the
responsibility of the Ukrainian people
and the rest of your European societies
that want to live in a free world and
continue deciding on our future
altogether thank you
thank you very much chair now for the
renew Europe group it's Chairman's
defenses
thank you very much Madam president and
colleagues the ukrainians are carrying
the burden of European Security on the
shoulders however the ukrainians are not
yet members of our Union and are not
involved in our decision making that's
why this Parliament has always been
carrying the voice of Ukrainian people
we've always been at the avant-garde
this Parliament has voted for and
obtained in unprecedented sanctions and
embargo on version fossil fuels the
granting of the candidate candidate
state test to Ukraine and envelopes of
financial military aid today this is a
role continued to play and it's a year
now that the ukrainians have been
fighting experts tell us this spring can
be pivotal there's a forecast of a new
offensive from the Russians of parallel
violence we my group welcomes with
gratitude and relief the decision of
member states send the U.S to provide
tanks to Ukraine it was a necessary
decision it was a just decision
nevertheless my group calls for the
efforts to be continued we need to
expand the list of sanctions
considerably to 6 000 individuals the
heart of Putin's dictatorship the
progressive integration of Ukraine into
the union is also a key priority the
single Market structural programs the
European funds should be progressively
extended to our Ukrainian friends at
each stage of sanctions and integration
we know that the Kremlin will threaten
us however I say this to European
leaders
it's not uh Russia who is fixing uh
Redlands here Russia's already
passed the only real red line which is
violating international law the basis of
our collective security they've got Pat
stepped over the moral Red Line
committing war crimes and crime
um crime against humanity let's not fall
into the Trap of listen to their
propaganda a black male apocalyptic
predictions we've been hearing them for
a year now where would the Ukraine be
today if we if we had listened to the
Kremlin and what if we we needed to
listen to the people of Ukraine
now imagine where Ukraine would be if we
stopped listening to them once and for
all let's not have fear continue our
fight and let's continue to support
Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you very much
chair now on behalf of the greens Miss
from common tolbertell
financially
thank you vice president
we have now watched 12th month of
Russia's brutal war and 12th month of
Ukraine's Brave resistance Against All
Odds the people of Ukraine prove to the
world that they can and will win this
war for their Victory Ukraine needs our
continued support we must increase the
pressure of sanctions on the Russian
economy and provide Ukraine with a
weapon it needs the morale and
motivation of Ukraine Defenders combined
with our Western support is what truly
terrifies Putin but winning the war
alone will not be enough for an EU
membership other fundamental steps need
to be taken the sooner the better
even during a war Ukraine is fighting
corruption this progress should now be
made structural and accelerated tenfold
Societies in Europe need assurance that
oligars pulling dirty schemes
governmental officials stealing from the
Army and judges robbing the country will
all be brought to Justice fairly and
transparently media Freedom cannot be
compromised not even during wartime
democracy is strong when power is shared
not monopolized this is what sets apart
Ukraine from Russia Ukraine is a
European state with a European future
its people will not walk the European
path alone they have the entire
Democratic World behind them thank you
so much
foreign thank you very much the next
speaker should be on behalf of the ID
group Mr badella I don't see him in the
Hemi cycle which means we'll continue
with the European conservatives and
reformist group Mr MS shidler
sort of the parents of engines and
president
um commissioner ladies and gentlemen
the future of Ukraine lies lies within
the European Union Ukraine is determined
to put an end to the war as soon as
possible to win the war or and to become
a member of the European Union the EU
needs Ukraine
just as Ukraine needs the European union
we need to be more determined efficient
effective
unequivocal and solidary we have to
shown solidarity if we adopt sanctions
we need to follow them follow them
through in a consistent manner but today
Ukraine mainly needs weapons arms it
will not win the war without without
weapons we are aware of that but is it
really so that we all have sufficient
determination and will to support
Ukraine in a military way a humanitarian
Aid is needed economic aid is needed as
well we need to extend our thanks to the
European Society to the citizens who
have shown how determined they are to
support refugees who flee Ukraine and
come to our countries I would like to
thank Poland Paul English women and men
and I must want to say that I'm proud of
Poland which is showing every day that
it really understands that the future of
the European Union the security of the
European Union of all of us all depends
on Ukraine winning the war and that
we're all doing our best in order to
provide support but will let me once
again stress that Ukraine needs arms
first of all we must all remember about
that thank you
thank you very much
now we'll move on to the left group the
chairman of the group Mr Sheridan has
the floor
thank you very much Madam president
there was a previous speaker who I was
listening to very attentively
where we're talking about War and Peace
in Europe that we're discussing it's
about life and death in our immediate
neighborhood and I have to admit
that I'm disappointed
in all of the speeches that were made to
date
there hasn't been an underscoring of
returning to peace as quickly as
possible in Ukraine of course Russia is
responsible and has begun the war
against Ukraine and of course we provide
solidarity to them to the civilian
population above all who in this war are
having to suffer so terribly
and the attacks on civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine by Russia are
Criminal
but all of that doesn't mean that we
should fall into some form of tunnel
vision and turn solely to Military
Support
on the country because of this terrible
War
it is incumbent on us as members of the
European Parliament to find paths to
peace
Mr Lula the Brazilian president
called on the International Community
making an offer to work together with
China
to exert the greatest amount of
political pressure on Russia and
starting a peace initiative and I think
this European Summit of heads and state
and government should should assume an
intention to support that
and I think
it's high time
to make sure
that
Mr Schultz Mr McCall
um
Miss Fonda lion should go to the United
Nations should go to China should go to
Brazil to work on a serious peace
initiative to demand peace negotiations
and to bring a sustainable end to this
war nobody's on by on in favor of Putin
our solidarity should multifaceted for
Ukraine we should work against oligarchs
we should provide financial support for
reconstruction and also help European
prospects for Ukraine but the best form
of support and Aid is to do our utmost
to make sure that this horrible war is
finished as soon as possible
and to exploit all avenues
to bring a an end to this conflict
that's affecting civilians so much and I
hope that in this house there'll be more
reflection and instead of a war war that
we look for more jaw jaw
s
thank you very much now Mr Deutsch is
the next speaker
thank you very much
Hungary condemns the Russian aggression
we are of course stand by Ukraine and
defend its territorial integrity
the Ukraine's accession to the EU is
important and we've been helping the
Ukraine with so much energy since the
beginning of the invasion hungary's
humanitarian program means that we've
welcomed more than one million Ukrainian
refugees but on the basis of the most
recent decisions
the European bureaucrats have said that
Russian
sanctions are putting Russia in such
difficulty that Russia won't be able to
continue its war and yet the war
continues to be brutal so what they said
would happen hasn't happened on the
country since the beginning of the
sanctions inflation has soared the
financial crisis has been continuing the
economic crisis and the sanctions are
destroying Europe we need peace and that
is why we need a ceasefire
we don't want war in Europe any longer
Europe should try and move forward with
peace talks we have to do everything we
can in the interest of Peace
thank you very much moving on to the
other speakers from the groups first of
all
missini you have the floor
not someday but this year this requires
hundreds of Tanks fighter jets and
long-range missiles now
Ukraine must be invited to EU membership
negotiations not someday but this year
our goal is to Grant EU membership to
Ukraine before the end of this decade
bold and Swift eu's decisions on
Ukraine's future in EU will help the
country to ultimately defeat Putin NATO
must welcome Ukraine
through its open doors not at some point
in the future but as soon war
hostilities on its territory end that
means this year we have to be ready for
that
that you must act as a geopolitical
leader because this is a historic trance
for us all we need Ukraine
we're done for a colleague and Industry
thank you very much now Mr Marcus we
have the floor
the question for president thank you
president
um
cancel commissioner dear colleagues the
war of aggression against Ukraine will
go down in history is one of the major
crimes against international law against
the country against the people now Putin
has totalitarian fantasies but he will
be condemned by history and we
Remembered in Russia as the individual
who led the country into an unfair War
the EU has Provide support for Ukraine
and we must continue that so therefore
we strengthen we support strengthening
economic and humanitarian micro
Financial political support and Military
Support as well so the Ukraine continue
to defend itself sustain its economy and
help its people
we want
Europe to continue United without
divisions between the countries along we
need to stand with uh zielinski and his
people we want to as early as possible
we can build a an Avenue to peace
thank you very much now Mr astrovichus
you have the floor
Madam chair Council representative
commissioner the aquatics
as a project of for peace and
cooperation the European Union has
withstood many historical challenges and
remained highly appreciated and enjoyed
by its citizens
Ukraine's aspiration to join our Union
is an understandable logic and right
choice for Ukraine the European union
membership means choosing between
democracy and Russian authoritarianism
between freedom and occupation
the granting of candidate status to
Ukraine has Justified the youth nature
as an open and forward-looking
geopolitical actor our trusted partner
who continues Democratic reforms while
resisting Russia's war of aggression
needs to be invited to start accession
negotiations now
such a decision will not only testify to
our commitment to our neighborhood
policy but will also strengthen Ukraine
as a state rise with spirits of
ukrainians and give them hope
for those who hesitate
allow me to encourage you in words of
Robert Schumann
spoken on a day of signing the human
declaration
start of the quote
World Peace cannot be safeguarded
without the making of creative efforts
proportionate to the dangers which
threaten it thank you
thank you very much
now Mr lagodinski has the floor
foreign
who would have thought a year ago that
this European Union would be able to
show that we can meet the challenges
on historic occasions who would have
thought that now we have to make our
European Union in a future-proof shape
for further enlargement so that Ukraine
the Ukrainian
society and economy be fit for the Union
our Ukrainian friends know that we're on
their side but we need to tread this
path together
and that is our logic of peace that is
our logic of Peace we don't always agree
with the commission but on this occasion
on this journey that the commission is
taking to Kiev is something that's
happening on behalf of all citizens of
the European Union they want to see our
logic of peace they want to see evidence
of that
because they're seeing attacks
humiliation and plunder but the
Ukrainian people have stood against this
robustly because this these people want
free freedom and peace and we will
support them thank you Mr lagodinsky
miss bonfrisco's the next speaker thank
you madam chair president
thank you president
Minister Johnson
and good morning to commissioner Han as
well those who believe in the principles
and values of the current rule-based
order in the world will have to
fight against Russian aggression for
different reasons we cannot accept the
use of force to take territory of other
countries we cannot allow the return of
imperialism and colonialism we cannot
remain indifferent while the civilians
are being massacred this war is between
between an invading dictatorship
and a country that is defending itself
now we have to look at our response to
Russian aggression we have to make sure
that we work with NATO allies and
like-minded partners we have to dissuade
China from the temptation of annexing
Taiwan and getting rid of democracy in
Taiwan we have to promote fundamental
freedoms and the social model that uh
sets us apart we've got to strengthen
our leadership in global strategic
Partnerships we have to support the rule
of law all over the world because it's
only the rule of law that supports and
creates peace between peoples and
countries so therefore our parliamentary
role today is to make sure that our
citizens obtain the right information
and that we can guarantee consensus we
have to increase the military
expenditure of our Sovereign countries
and the West thank you
thank you very much now miss fortiga you
have the floor
thank you president colleagues I'm
deeply grateful for all Europeans do for
Ukraine in particular I'm proud of my
people now let me talk quickly and and
shortly it's a sanctioned sanctions
sanctions without circumventing of them
weapons that are necessary to defeat
Russia delivered to Ukraine immediately
and real fighting impunity including
crime of
aggression not just as a slogan used but
by Angie ngos
and commissioner
running marathon in times of earthquake
and people shedding their blood for our
values is not advisable we have to have
clear timeline for agreed with Ukraine
for for accession of the EU and NATO
thank you
very much now Mr Wallace you have the
floor
[Music]
so those guys know band 12 opposition
parties and use the war
to carry so deeply anti-democratic labor
reforms
the International Trade union
Confederation which unites more than 200
million Walkers worldwide are protesting
against the laws
General Secretary Sharon borrow said in
a statement it has got tests that
Ukrainian workers who defend the country
and care for the injured sick and
displaced and now being attacked by
their own Parliament
so this is attacking the people and
structures necessary for a country to
win a war
he's forcing through the most dramatic
privatization program in the country's
history a fire sale of public assets to
Western vulture funds
what would that do for Ukrainian Society
since when did handing over public
assets to Big Business ever help the
people of any country this is a program
for even deeper corruption and
inequality the EU is promising the sun
moon and stars to Ukraine including
fast-tracking EU accession be careful
what you wish for
thank you very much we now go on to Mr
nicolawa alabanos
the debate today and the resolution in
itself speak volumes
the US the EU and NATO and the
respective governments are escalating
War operations by sending armored
vehicles and they also want to send
fighter jets on the Russian side they're
escalating their operations especially
in donbus there is this imperialist war
and it's the Ukrainian people and the
Russian people that are giving up their
lives for this and the EU is escalating
the situation and of course is looking
at energy agreements and Investments to
the tune of billions of Euro and
competing against the U.S to do so these
Agreements are jeopardizing the future
of the Ukrainian people in order to
secure capitalist profits and this
clearly shows that war stems from a
monopoly rivalry it is carried out by
the bourgeoisie and it's the peoples
that die so that Masters can have their
meals and increase so many parties are
supporting this they are fueling the
escalation not only are they not
protecting fundamental rights but the
people are the target it's only the
people who have to throw off the Yoke
and make sure that we put an end to
these murderous alliances
thank you very much Mr halitzki is the
next speaker
ladies and gentlemen we all want to have
peace in Europe but in order for this to
happen Ukraine has to win this war
that we need to realize together which
is why this Summit is so important
it's so important for it to end with
specific actions because we there is no
time for reconsidering what equipment
we're going to send
the soonest possible as much as possible
the most serious and the heaviest
equipment not only Leo Parts missiles
fighter planes everything Ukraine has to
win this war because it's fighting for
Europe's future it's fighting for us as
well then sanctions we've heard about
sanctions many times already they must
be even heavier even stronger more
symbolic let's remember next year there
is going to be Olympic games without
Russian uh athletes without Belarusian
athlete they cannot represent countries
which are aggressors which attacked
other countries in Europe those are
symbolic gestures as well Olympics are
for Peace So sanctions and more
assistance due to grain thank you thank
you
thank you very much the next speakers Mr
shimoshovich
Madam president
war is progressing before we will come
to an end it will escalate Ukraine
cannot lose this war because this would
destroy the European order based on rule
of law we will continue all assistance
for the Ukrainian Nation we will help in
rebuilding country after the war as well
we want Ukraine to join us in the
European Union and we are ready to open
a path for quick commencement of
accession negotiations it will be needed
to give the people hope
but everyone must understand that
enlargement is not only a political
process and we cannot make promises that
we cannot keep because we are risking
disappointment
the heroism of Ukrainian soldiers is
admirable people are suffering that
requires our compassionate understanding
and solidarity
helping refugees is a moral test we
shall persevere Ukraine will prevail and
the European dream will come true for
Ukraine thank you a colleague thank you
very much the next speakers Mr for
hofstadt thank you very much it's a Pity
that Mr the one is not longer in the in
the room after everything what he said
he should go to chromatosk maybe where
yesterday again an apartment block was
brutally attacked and destroyed by
Russia the only way to end this war is a
victory of Ukraine that's the way to end
the war the fastest as possible and for
that
I hope Mr Han you are in direct contact
with Mr sunderline I suppose on on what
she will do in in Kiev
my impression is that it is a weak
proposal what you are bringing to Kiev
on weapons for example I see no
long-range missiles in the package
on on sanctions uh Mr seizure has said
it it's already a year that we are
asking to put the full backbone of the
restaurant Putin regime under sanctions
regime and the commission is not moving
on that
the same on the assets the frozen assets
of the Russian Central Bank it's
possible to size them to freeze them and
to transfer them to Ukraine that's
possible there is a legal service of the
council Mr that's something that cannot
be disputed and they have said that it
is possible and and finally a fast track
membership the 2026. if I see what is
happening on corruption in Hungary I
think and I see the actions that are
happening in Ukraine Ukraine deserves a
place in Europe thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much moving on now miss
gregorova you have the floor
thank you chair and dear colleagues I am
an Unapologetic fan of you enlargement
which is why I welcome president
zelenski's commitment to reforms
changing legal social and political
reality to align with our European aqui
even during wartime I have high hopes
for the upcoming Summit to bring Ukraine
even closer to the EU family in the
European family they already are
furthermore the summit must convey
strength and commitment also from the EU
in political economic and Military
assistance but also reinforce its
humanitarian support especially the
issue of forced filtration of people in
russian-occupied territories and
deportation far far east as well as Ford
forestry adoption of children into
Russian families the summit also brings
an opportunity to discuss all necessary
instruments to try Russia for all the
committed crimes which is a mass for the
international order thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
now we have Mr bardella the floor is yes
thank you very much Madam president
uh political leader should always strive
for a peace within and peace outside so
within the nation and between nations
and if we don't have this and freedom
disappears we can be fragile and can be
broken at any moment almost a year and
almost a year ago Russia invaded Ukraine
committed crimes against the civilian
population and has illegally occupied a
big part of its territory by doing this
Moscow has given the ukrainians a common
enemy and has given them a spirit of
resistance and more intense and concrete
existence compared to before all the
peoples of the world including obviously
the Ukraine have to be able to resist
the shadow of the Empire Ukraine has
legitimate right and even the duty to
defense its territory its integrity and
borders as far as we're concerned
history concerns us and has taught us
peace is very fragile and we're very
aware of this on our continents so we
have the duty to make sure that the rest
of Europe doesn't fall into war
and this terrible Machinery we need to
provide assistance and Aid to our
neighbor that has been attacked we have
to open our arms to the refugees and
help with the military equipment but
we're giving tanks that France doesn't
even have for its own use but there
could be this could lead to more
escalation and co-belligerence let us
remember that we were talking yesterday
about military equipment for defense now
we're talking of just a handful of tanks
and then we're going to be talking we're
talking about fighter jets and who knows
even nuclear weapons in the future
uh Russia's devastating whole Landscapes
families and homes we have to be very
careful of not discarding the
possibility of Peace saying that peace
is impossible means that war will be
more probable than ever we have to make
sure that peace conditions exist only a
big Continental peace treaty will
continue to offer the whole of Europe
the stability it needs in a world that
is already marked by geopolitical
instability we need to talk about peace
and to strive for it that doesn't mean
that we're sacrificing the independence
and freedom of the Ukraine on the
contrary it's the opposite if we want
peace we need to pave the way through
our deeds and words thank you
thank you very much Mr zimnyox the next
speaker
Madam president despite all the sanction
measures that have been adopted the
IMF considers that the Russian economy
continues to grow and yet our citizens
are becoming impoverished because of
inflation and food price inflation
so we know that only China turkey and
obviously the US are profiting from
these sanctions
we're being a bit naive in this
parliament in April 2022 Mr zelenski
allowed negotiations to fall once he got
some weapons ensured so the result has
been civilians and soldiers being killed
needlessly
uh cities towns and Villages being
destroyed and no realistic chance for a
Ukrainian Victory nevertheless you want
to continue and extend the provision of
arms because ten thousands of of people
being killed is not enough for you so
I'm calling on the EU states to leave
this obvious wrong path and accept
that we need to deal with a different
reality than the one you seem to see in
Parliament
this is an undignified loss of life
please dinsky Mr lagodinski please
the next speakers Mr vashiorkovsky
your mic
okay okay please thank you madam chair I
would like to support all the scholarly
who mentioned that to end this world
Ukraine has to win the war to win the
World firstly we have to provide all
kinds of assistance to Ukraine this is
what they speak firstly food from the
summit
political economic and Military
assistance all kind of weapons supposed
to be delivered to win the war and
second the what they expect from the
summit a clear and fast perspective of
membership of the European Union
based on Copenhagen criteria and I keep
coming there now nothing else we cannot
treat Ukraine as a guinea pig as a
laboratory of liberal-less Visions thank
you
thank you
thank you very much
now Mr willemson has the floor
let us stand in solidarity with the
Ukraine the brave train and truck
drivers the nurses the municipal workers
the miners the farmers they keep the
country running often unnoticed and
poorly paid and they bleed and die
because of Putin's war of aggression
their courage and that of civil society
and trade unions is amazing they need
our help now they will also need our
help once the bullets stopped flying and
the aggressor withdraws dear
commissioner
one thing the summit can do one thing to
Summit should do is to make sure that
Ukraine is not weighted down by having
to repay huge amounts to its creditors
the moment the hostilities ends this
will give Ukraine the possibility to
take care of its population to protect
those Who Bore the cost of the war to
build a fair future
thank you soon
thank you very much
now Mr Uric has the floor
I'm listening you talking about wars
about weapons about sanctions rackets
the fighter jets
Etc but nobody has yet appealed to peace
the war in Ukraine has been going on for
more than a year and the politicians
have been fighting who's more Prussian
who's more Pro Ukrainian but you keep
forgetting that you should especially
take care of your own nations of course
it's easy shouting let's send more
weapons let's send more missiles let's
make the world bigger because you
colleagues politicians are not going to
the war that it would be real people who
would be fighting in the war regular
people but regular people are sick of
the high prices and of the dying
and I would really wish in the next
Summit between the EU and Ukraine would
bring not only more appeals to sending
missiles at tanks but if it would bring
real solutions and real appeals to peace
and if I could decide I would be trying
for that thank you thank you
thank you very much the next speakers Mr
moishan
president thank you very much thank you
very much then to Dear colleagues we
have all seen this year that we can only
live in safety and stability within the
borders of the European Union if we are
surrounded in our Eastern neighborhood
by countries which are safe stable at
peace this is why I am telling to you
today that the fight that the people of
Ukraine are fighting is also our fight
this is why it is right to support
Ukraine and it is also in the
fundamental interest of the European
Union to support Ukraine we did a lot
this year and I think we can be proud of
what we did in terms of sanctions in
terms of financial support the 18
billion euros put forward by the
European commission will allow the
Ukrainian state to function this year to
pay salaries to pay pensions to keep
hospitals to keep schools going and
commissioner Han thank you for your
personal engagement also for making this
possible we did a lot but more has to be
done and we do not need excuses for what
cannot be done but we need arguments and
Solutions on what can be done more on
sanctions support financially as much as
is needed and make sure that even before
Ewok session becomes possible we bring
Ukraine closer to European projects
integration into the single Market will
help Ukraine will help ourselves and the
principle whatever we do for Ukraine we
do for more device well thank you very
much
thank you
very much next is Mr Pizza you have the
floor thank you madam chair
I welcome this initiative together in
Kiev to witness the extraordinary
courage and resilience of ukrainians and
show our support yes this is the first
European Union Summit to be held in the
country where war is Raging so its
historical significance must meet
tangible results with clear guidelines
and plans for immediate future the key
message of the summit must be that we
stand with Ukraine and count on its
European Union perspective furthermore I
think it's essential for our citizens to
clarify some doubts fears and even
propaganda that Ukraine is rejecting
diplomatic Solutions since 90s there
have been many diplomatic initiatives
Minsk one and two Normandy format let
alone Budapest memorandum and they were
all bluntly disrespected by Russia when
it started its aggression yes peace
should remain the ultimate goal but as
they pay the highest possible price in
this war true peace for ukrainians only
means their victory over invader thank
you
thank you
thank you very much next is Mr tudoraki
you have the floor sir
thank you madam chair the commissioner
the council Representatives their
colleagues
it is said the times
the time and resources are everything in
Wartime I would add hope and morale
I hear more and more arguing that giving
hope to Ukraine and Moldova last year
when accepting the candidate status was
wrong because it created false
expectations
well yes
that historic decision did create
expectations legitimate expectations
that once we went down the path of
thinking and acting strategically
geopolitically that we would stay on
that path
working hard to start the process of
accession negotiations
like our resolution says is a minimum
that we must do to be consistent with
ourselves and with the commitment that
we made to the Ukrainian cause and
people we cannot afford fatigue or
commodity just like the Iranians on the
front cannot
let's be courageous in maintaining hope
for Ukraine that wants to be in the
European family Slava Ukraine thank you
very much the next speakers Mr delunda
tax me caref thank you very much Madam
president ladies and gentlemen
Ukraine belongs to Europe
the Russian regime and Vladimir Putin
uh
trying to apply their versions of
History their falsification of History
by saying that Ukraine doesn't exist as
a nation that it's actually the same
Nation as Russia
and that is the falsification of History
if you look back through history then
yes obviously there are ties to Russia
but they're more and stronger ties for
example
to the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
there are many other links to Austria to
Germany if you go even further back to
Constantinople and the Byzantine Empire
it is no not by chance
that there is a growing democratic
force in Ukraine that makes it different
to Russia and that's why Russia is
scared that's why Russia is trying to
falsify history because they're trying
to see Ukraine as something different
but Ukraine belongs in Europe
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr vilimski
thank you sir
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
what I can't understand is that all
those speakers who come up and talk
about promoting peace and peace
negotiations
then give rise to this massive
state of indignity from you
we're seeing hundreds of thousands of
people who had died
difficult to know how many soldiers have
died
so if you times that by what you might
expect we're talking about 250 000
people who are killed or injured in this
situation I say this has to be stopped
we have to do everything to promote
peace to promote peace negotiations and
start those negotiations with your
policies of sanctions and provision of
weapons you've got
um tanks are you talking about we've
heard mention of jets and submarines and
who knows what I think that's the wrong
approach I would like Europe that was
based on peace and prosperity for all
that we push for peace and bring an end
finally to this dying thank you thank
you very much the next speakers Mr
chanetsky
ladies and gentlemen
first of all I would like to correct
some fake news that have been spread in
this Hall with all due respect to
colleagues we must not say that we want
to send our soldiers to Ukraine this is
not true what we discuss is the
dispatching of arms and arms must be
sent to Ukraine but it would be wrong to
assume that it would be wrong to mislead
the European public opinion by saying
that we want to send troops one of our
colleagues from Germany said that Russia
is a beneficiary of this war that their
economy is growing this is not true
they are registering a reduction in GDP
by 3.3 percent
although initial estimates had been
greater we anticipated 15 drop so we
must not say that Russia is winning by
Waging War and let me say that this is a
very important Summit and we need to
support Ukraine in the NATO
thank you very much now Mr radachovsky
in connection with the summit e Ukraine
I have a very pragmatic question
we're all convinced that together with
the us so we will defeat Russia
but do we also have a plan B
what if we don't defeat Russia nobody
has managed to do so in history
as a Slovak and slav I would like to ask
our West European friends your fathers
your grandfathers when fighting Russia
in the second world war they ended up
killing around 20 million of Slavs
Russians ukrainians Belarusian serbs and
as a bonus also 6 million innocent Jews
what do you think how many ukrainians
and Russians will be killed by the time
this war ends but you probably don't
care you simply have it in your genes
just stop this madness because you will
end up choking on the slav blood
let's negotiate ceasefire let's
negotiate peace and all the excuses
referring to Napoleon to Hitler de Putin
it's just not acceptable otherwise so
you will end up shooting each other as
rabbits
thank you very much the next speakers Mr
cabelius
dear colleagues
the keys to sustainable peace on
European continent are in the hands of
Ukraine sustainable peace in Europe is
Possible only if Russian people will
transform their country back to
democracy because democracies are not
fighting each other the West needs to
have a strategy how to assist such a
transformation first of all Russia needs
to be deputyized this means total
military defeat of Russia international
Tribunal for Putin an invitation for
Akron to become a member of NATO such an
invitation would send the most powerful
signal to Russians as a dream to restore
the empire is gone from Another Side a
unit to assist Russians with an
inspirational example of success of
Ukraine such a success of Ukraine can be
created only through Ukraine's
integration into you just like the
success story of the Central Europe was
created
geopolitical integration to the West is
no less important than the lower parts
of Abrams for Green's defense because
this is the only way to sustainable
peace on the European continent and that
is why Summit should establish the
integration Ramstein in order also to
deliver integration
[Applause]
thank you president
today the war in Ukraine
is about to turn into a huge European
catastrophe
there are millions of people who are
afraid that the conflict can expand
the people who believe that
sending thanks and heavy Weaponry is
going is going to lead to an end to this
war but
I'm not sure this is the case what is
the next step what are we going to send
tomorrow fighter jets
troops
nuclear arms
the um
Ukraine is standing against
a military power that has a huge nuclear
potential
if we keep on like this
Ukraine is is condemned to a very long
war that is going to damage it for a
long time what I don't hear from
Brussels is negotiations
and we need negotiations
it's important for the citizens of
Ukraine
thank you very much the next speaker is
miss wazel you have the floor
dear colleagues now more than ever
Ukraine needs our aid
but I'm hearing strange noises from
Europe we have provided military aid but
some people say that we are involved in
this war now and
they should not be listened to
they are lying clearly and we
those they are the ones who are linked
to a Russia where there are no European
troops in Ukraine we merely give them
the um uh method to defend themselves we
need to remain Resolute with every uh
day we lose without some limited trade
it's more lives lost I think Ukraine's
also wanting to join the EU need to make
sure that they slow down however in in
Ukraine continuing with this reforms
whilst they're being at War there's a
fight against corruption from president
zielinski which is unprecedented let's
say it's quite clearly there's certain
member states that should be doing the
same thing I can I think that we should
be adopting more sanctions against
Russia however our economies are
resisting better than expected Russia
has not uh stepped back from this
aggression and their testing our
determination we would be wrong to step
back
[Applause]
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr sayoshki
for Ukraine a decisive moment approaches
with a new Russian offensive coming
Ukraine needs boost not cold shower and
nice words
Ukraine is not getting enough and
quickly enough
there is no reason for EU being so
self-satisfied and self-congratulatory
Mr commissioner
for what it does for Ukraine
because it does things below its needs
be below the needs of Ukraine below EU
capacity on weapons EU is
underperforming compared to U.S cowardly
hesitant and over cautious attitudes
prevail
Ukraine needs fighter jets and
long-range artillery now on money EU is
performing far below its weight gives
loans instead of grant money that leads
Ukraine into a sovereign debt crisis
on accession perspective many age
to dash Ukraine's hopes for Swift ux
session and calls them unrealistic there
are mainly Russian distenders
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr gunyoshi
dear colleagues the people of Ukraine
expressed unequivocally their desire to
join the community of Western
democracies instead of moscow's tyranny
Europe was right to hear that desire and
Grant candidate status to Ukraine
however full membership has conditions
that need to be fulfilled sustainable
peace and stability need to be attained
prior to integration in order to avoid
taking on a divided country with
internal division we have had that
negative experience before and suffer
the consequences thus sustainable peace
and stability in the Ukraine have two
prerequisites restoring the territorial
Integrity of Ukraine in full the EU
needs to help Ukraine to win this war
with all it has
second Ukraine needs to reach out to
ethnic minorities living in its
territory all of them and guarantee
their rights as Ukrainian citizens and
ethnic minorities the EU should support
that endeavor by providing best
practices to Ukraine and help the
transition thank you
thank you very much the next speakers Mr
myanmon
gracias
thank you very much Madam President we
have to continue helping Ukraine in
these decisive moments including
increasing the sending of Weaponry we
have to make sure that almost the whole
International Community joins forces and
condemns Russian aggression there are
still too many countries that
incomprehensibly uh sit on the fence or
remain neutral I just don't understand
we have to make sure that we look at the
issue of sanctions and that they join
the sanctions that Western and
like-minded countries have gone for
the least that we should do is make sure
that third countries don't help Russia
get around the sanctions uh well uh I
heard about the case of South Africa and
their attitude is unacceptable I hope
that Mr Burrell who went there was
persuasive and that the South African
authorities will start changing their
position we all have to be in our guard
and make sure that our countries
enforce these sanctions the UK have
increased two-fold the number of Staff
working in the treasury
uh Interruption by the president
thank you
very much Miss Mr Neha grasku is the
next speaker of the floor
is
not only fighting for its own
independence it's fighting for us as
well the brutal attack of the Russian
Federation against Ukraine was just the
beginning of a bloody plan meant to
reconquer influence in the region the
support of the EU of the United States
of NATO allies has allowed a blocking of
this offensive but the risk continues to
be very high the threat of a new Russian
attack still exists an increased
military presence on the Eastern flank
and in the NATO countries including
Romania support for Ukraine support for
Moldova maintaining sanctions against
Russia all these measures are essential
for victory and for possible future
peace negotiations at the same time we
need to increase the European capacity
for military production especially in
the Frontline States we need to support
the population in order to increase the
resiliency of our society but also we
should rebuild Ukraine on New on a new
basis uh based on the fight against
corruption and based on the rights of
all minorities we can win the this war
but in order to do this European leaders
must do that by maintaining our values
and our Unity thank you so much
thank you Mr negrasku now Mr ranchel you
have the floor
dear commissioner
almost a year ago Ukraine was
horrifically attacked by the Russian
regime every day every week war crimes
are being committed in Ukraine in this
Summit between the EU and the Ukraine
it's absolutely vital to ensure that we
maintain financial support humanitarian
support logistical support and all that
support which is necessary to strengthen
the military capacity of Ukraine
finally
the European Union and NATO have made
tanks available to Ukraine unfortunately
we see that the Portuguese government
continues to hesitate there's
discussions between the ministry of
defense and the foreign minister the
Portuguese government it continues to be
against the European integration of
Ukraine we all have to make an effort to
support president zielinski in Ukraine
in military terms of humanitarian terms
and in financial terms
tank
thank you the next speaker is Miss
blinkerichooter we have the floor
thank you president colleagues it will
soon be one year since Ukraine and its
people are fighting for their freedom
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
unjustified military aggression of
Russia has irreversibly changed the
geopolitical situation of Europe and the
whole world and the whole world has seen
the true face of Russia and the Kremlin
regime so it's time to mobilize and make
bold political economic and financial
decisions to help Ukraine fight and
defeat Russian aggression let's not
forget that Ukraine's victory over
Russia is a guarantee of security
freedom and democracy for us all
that's or why concrete the solutions
must be made for special Tribunal for
the Russian crime of aggression for the
compensation to victims for the fund or
for Recovery of Ukraine and for
sustainable help military and otherwise
to Ukraine and
um also the determination to support
membership of for Ukraine in the EU
Monday thank you very much Mr Mandel is
the next speaker
thank you very much president
commissioner colleagues it has been
nearly a year that Putin Russia has
waged War
also militarily against Ukraine but the
hybrid Warfare against all of us the
Free World especially Europe
was already ongoing for many years also
in February last year and has been
ongoing now now for many years but
Europe defense its citizens its freedom
and to wants to achieve peace with the
means and measures unprecedented this
wasn't expected by Putin Russia and this
is why we have to underline that Europe
is using the European peace facility
exactly for what it was meant to be used
for
and Europe is also fighting back in a
bloodless way against the bloody war
attack in terms of sanctions yes within
Europe the leadership of server is of
concern the leadership of Hungary is of
concern but the alignment in the unity
are unprecedented and will remain so
it's good to have the EU Ukraine Summit
this week it's good to talk about even
more help in terms of military in terms
of sanctions in terms of reconstruction
in the future and I have no doubt that
freedom and peace will be restored
foreign thank you very much the next
speaker is Mr bashesko
thank you madam president
thank you commissioner Han
infrastructure
critical infrastructure civilian and
Military of Ukraine is daily being hit
by rockets launched by Aviation by ships
from terrestrial sites in this
Gravely affects the population and the
capacity of the Ukrainian Army in order
to give a chance to Ukraine to defend
its national territory we must make
available to the Ukrainian Army all the
necessary means to neutralize the
military logistics the air bases the
ships and the sites from which Rockets
are being launched
on the territory of the Russian
Federation
as far as the European Road of Ukraine
here Ukraine must understand that the
new minority law which their Parliament
adopted must be modified in the sense
suggested by the Venice Commission in
order to guarantee the rights of
minorities thank you very much
thank you very much the next speakers Mr
Dorfman
thank you for four seats in the head
thank you president commissioner ladies
and gentlemen the war in Ukraine has
also affected food security and Food
Supplies in Europe and the rest of the
world it's good that the commission has
tried to find and open up new ways to
get food out of the Ukraine especially
after a closure of Black Sea Roots but
the new export routes directly to the
European Union have had enough had
effects in Farmers especially in the
Eastern and Southern parts of the
European Union and it's called headaches
for them even if a small amount of the
exports in Meats for example being
provided to third countries
more than 60 percent of Maize and
sunflower is ending up here which of
course gives rise to problems of course
we want to open up possibilities for
Ukrainian Farmers to sell their products
to the European Union but we don't want
our Farmers to be put under pressure as
a result so we have to assume that
responsibility and help our farmers in
the EU but then we have to make sure in
the coming years and months and years we
have to make sure that they're the
process to approximate Ukraine to the EU
that we can keep an eye on that
Commonwealth sneaks thank you very much
the next speakers Mr teras you have the
floor
dear colleagues Ukraine has fought
bravely against Russia for almost nine
years the full-scale attack that Russia
launched in February last year is a
clear sign that Putin's regime goal is
to destroy Western way of life
our task is to help Ukraine as much as
we need as they need today Ukraine needs
more weapons and Ukraine needs a plan
for recovery
the EU Ukraine Summit must give Ukraine
a message of Hope
Ukraine belongs to European family
last but not least Russian and
belarussian athletes should not compete
on the Paris Olympic Games next year
I'm collecting your support give your
signature to the letter I will send to
the president of European Council thank
you
colleague on
thank you very much the next speaker is
Mr stevinett
me now crane is thank you today what's
being decided in Ukraine is the future
of Europe whether we protect life
whether we protect the rights of the
weak and whether they can democratically
decide on the future or whether the
other side will win the other side that
has no respect to life no respect to the
law and just listen to its dictator the
ukrainians are now protecting the
freedom of the whole of Europe Iraq it's
our moral duty today to help them and to
increase not only economic and
humanitarian aid but also military aid
this is important for the future of
Europe
and it's been long talked about the
defense of Europe about the European
Army what we say today is that we
already have the European Army it is
precisely the Ukrainian Army we have
been talking about the priests project
but nobody has done more for the peace
project in Europe than Ukrainian so
therefore we need to help Ukraine on the
European path we need to put a very
concrete shape to the accession process
and we need to talk about the increase
of economic collaboration at the summit
about the increase of the area for
roaming coals or cooperation in energy
area all of this would be helpful not
only to the Ukrainian citizens but
especially and also to the EU citizens
okay thank you very much time so we have
more than five requests for the catch
the eye but as we are good in time I can
take them all so be prepared and we
start with our colleague Alex cars
please one minute
foreign
Europe but today
we decide the future of Europe in
Ukraine and that's why we can achieve
peace in the only way if
all the soldiers of Putin leave the
territory of Ukraine and
the territorial Integrity is restored in
Ukraine
so the summit should talk about
uh
abolishing all the gaps in sanctions the
Military Tribunal and all the weapons to
Crane are provided to chase out the
aggressor and the negotiations on the
Ukraine's membership started this year
I'd like to draw your attention it's
very important to connect Ukraine to the
EU
we have to think about transport links
especially railways
I'd like to thank on this occasion the
people of my country who donate to
Ukraine and take the refugees in their
homes
glory to Ukraine
thank you very much Miss demerel one
minute
thank you very much Madam president
the EU could turn this EU Ukraine Summit
into a peace Summit but instead they're
turning the clock back as if this were
1914 and they're saying that Ukraine has
to win this battle on the battlefield
what the
Mark milley said as head of the chief of
staff in the U.S who said it's
impossible for Ukraine to win this war
militarily so as NATO States would you
like to kick off the third world war
officially if not then stop these calls
for going to the battlefield look for a
political solution Ukraine has never
been as dependent on the west
economically and militarily than now
don't exploit this shamelessly don't
keep sending ukrainians to their death
find a solution because the EU would be
party to the war
on the battlefield the poor people from
Ukraine are bleeding to death and from
Russia so my call is to all of those
parties to war that direct and indirect
ones with NATO and the rest stop this
war
be a common snakes is
Mr kios is the next big one minute
thank you president Ukraine has already
lost almost 20 percent of its territory
to the Russian aggressor that means we
should increase the EU support to give
in order to liberate the occupied
territories we should increase the
financial and Military assistance at
least to the level of the United States
of America after all we are dealing with
a European War we all know that if the
Russians are not stopped and defeated in
Ukraine they will continue towards
Moldova the Baltic states maybe Poland
during the past 20 years we have been
encouraging Ukraine's European Ambitions
without offering adequate support our
goal should be the integration of
Ukraine in the European Union based on
an unprecedented program of economic
support thank you very much
thank you
colleague thank you very much the next
speaker will be miss grapini one minute
thank you madam president Minister
commissioner let me first thank my
fellow Romanian countrymen who have
helped millions of Ukrainian refugees
since last year when this bloody
conflict started yes I think we should
do everything we can in order to stop
the killing of Civilian population
innocent people are being killed there
and I think that your message
commissioner given today is a shy
message for peace we should give support
diplomatic support but we should also
give support to the citizens because
civilians there do not have food do not
have water do not have anything and we
must also go or focus on diplomatic
support but Ukraine must understand that
it must respect the rights of minorities
and that I what that is why I urge your
commissioner to check the uh law of the
minorities in Ukraine because Romanian
minority in Ukraine is not allowed to
speak Romanian to educate itself in
Romania and now there are persecutions
against Orthodox priests Romanian
priests thank you to inform you you are
all on the list I just mix up a little
bit the groups because of different
positions come like this the discussion
is maybe a little bit more interesting
so next uh is Mr pinita please
thank you very much Madam president
it will be one year since the war of
aggression in Ukraine carried out by
Russia and once again we reiterate our
condemnation we've been doing it from
the outset but we feel that the EU is
doing the opposite to what we should be
doing in the situation we cannot feel
that we're
um waging this war by harnessing NATO
and sending weaponry
it's not the people that win Wars as the
people that sacrifice their lives by
doing this we cannot feel that by
sending Weaponry we're going to win the
war and win back the territory territory
we also think it's painful that we have
a buried diplomacy uh for uh
and look what president Lula has said
together with Mexico China and the
Vatican there are clamoring for a
political and diplomatic solution and we
want diplomacy to make the tanks quiet
thank you Colleen lupus Mr Lopez Aguilas
the next speaker one minute
thank you president commissioner Han the
one it's been 12 months of an illegal
illegitimate uh of aggression against
Ukraine
um we need to have commitment to
sanctions against Russia we also need to
show solidarity with the people of
Ukraine who are suffering from this war
we have supported the confiscation of
assets from oligarchies we've also
strengthened Euro Jester and ensuring
cooperation with the international
criminal court so that we can ensure
there's no impunity for war crimes we've
also supported
um the Implement implant the setting up
of a special Tribune and the crime of
regression however from the 11 million
people who are fled from this world 4
million but wanted to stay in the EU
indefinitely and this means that we need
to strengthen the budget lines at an e
within the EU budget to support
solidarity in the states so they can
help these vulnerable people we just
need to ensure there's schooling for
children and above all for these people
there will be support from the s d group
thank you
to conclude Miss Cyrus davesa you have
the floor for one minute yes
thank you very much Madam president uh
thank you bear for being generous under
this catch the eye procedure I'll be
brief
six seven eight months is what we've
spent debating among allies trying to
decide whether we were going to send
tanks to Ukraine or not and it was
glaringly obvious from the outset that
it is absolutely necessary to give the
Ukrainian government and its people all
the necessary means to be able to tackle
this aggression and to get back their
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
now we're looking at long-range missiles
and fighter jets that's what's on the
table at the moment and in this house I
would like to say I turn to the Allies
the west and NATO please don't waste
another six seven or eight months
debating this issue please cut to the
Chase and deliver this because the
Ukrainian people need it
thank you
very much that brings us to the replies
first of all reply from the commission
to start with commissioner Han you have
the floor once again
thank you very much president Minister
ladies and gentlemen
first of all
thank you for this debate it has shown
once again that there is
unrestricted support
for Ukraine and its population
this war
I would say needs to be one I don't
think there is an alternative
I would also like to lead to peace
negotiations I think everybody would I
just wonder
where's the Russian dalaran
I don't know one
let's not forget either
there's been much lost sight of in the
debate
about the re-establishment of the
territorial Integrity of Russia
sometimes I got the impression that
we've reversed Who is the
who is responsible who is the victim
who's the aggressor I think we have to
understand who the aggression is and in
future we have to continue to reiterate
that and do everything to help Ukraine
regain its territorial integrity
and in that context Europe has done a
great deal if you look at what the
member states have done together with
the commission as well you combine those
the military humanitarian Aid to date it
is more than the USA has done just so
that we understand that and see it in
the right light
I find it regrettable
that Mr for hofstadt isn't here it was a
slightly populistic attack that he led
in saying in calling on the commission
to provide arms knowing that that is not
constitutionally possible according to
the treaties of the European Union
obviously we want to work together with
our member states to try and Achieve
that end and provide the right support
secondly
obviously there's consensus not just
here in this house
but Russia in the future will have to
contribute in reparations in
reconstruction of infrastructure and
many other areas of society that will
require funding and the resources
from the Russian Central Bank
that have been frozen in foreign Banks
will be designated to reconstruction and
reparation payments as well as monies
that belong to oligarchs but in legal
terms that is not a simple exercise than
anybody who has been involved in this in
any serious extent understands it is not
an easy approach but I think the moral
stance is clear and will have to be
followed up on there was also the
question as to why we're providing for
loans not grants but at the end of the
day that was the possibility we had to
help quickly but I would like to
underscore that the European member
states
have also agreed that in the coming 10
years that the interest on these loans
will be covered will be paid
and the servicing of capital will only
have to start as of the 30s
and so we'll see how we're going to deal
with that later on
we're debating here there are 15
colleagues
who are now in Ukraine
at this meeting of this commission with
the Ukrainian government
those are colleagues there who given
their portfolios and responsibilities
have topics that need to be addressed
that are current and topical in Ukraine
where they can help
but also when it comes to the accession
prospects for Ukraine they can support
them in those Endeavors those are two
tracks that we're taking in parallel
and and there's been mentioned made of
this already you can't really give a
discount on membership but we can have
active engagement and that's what we're
doing and that's what we'll do in the
future so thank you very much once again
for that strong level of support that
I've seen here in the debate
here today
to conclude
it's become a tradition
but nevertheless very important words
commissioner
now on behalf of the council Minister
Johnson go ahead
foreign
members commissioner thank you for all
the interventions and this exchange
shows once again the European
parliament's strong support for Ukraine
the EU Ukraine Summit will bring a
message of strong unwavering support a
way for the EU to say We Stand By Your
Side and that the future for Ukraine and
its citizens lies within the EU I also
listened carefully to you to all your
interventions about accountability and
further sanctions and as I said in my
introductory remarks those responsible
must be held accountable and on
sanctions We Stand ready to reinforce
more restrictive measures
we will further step up the ongoing the
Diplomatic efforts to support Ukraine in
all relevant International Forum calling
for the steadfast solidarity with
Ukraine and against Russia's war of
aggression we are ready to support
Ukraine's Initiative for a just peace
and we will continue stand by Ukraine
once peace has returned to reconstruct
and help make the future brighter for
the Ukrainian people we firmly stand
with Ukraine for as long as it takes
thank you very much and once again thank
you for your attention
thank you minister
I've received five motions for a
resolution to wind up the debate the
debate is closed and the vote will take
place today
let us move on to the next item on the
agenda here we have Council and
commission statements on the situation
of the former president of Georgia
Mikhail sakashvili
on behalf of the council will be hearing
from Minister Johnson
foreign
president honorable members of the
European Parliament allow me at this oh
open this debate on the situation no Mr
shakas really